I I do a lot of like that kind of like
weird Japan
Channel I have a lot of those um one
that hasn't been released yet as of this
video that I thought was funny was um I
know hideaki you know the creator of
Evangelical he got docs the other day
are you serious who knocks them some
random fan at a gas station what so so
the story goes is that hopefully that
video will be up by the time this
episode's up but like yeah basically
it's Anna was just like I'm just gonna
go for a drive oh I gotta go fill up
some gas so he just goes to his local
gas station fills it up the guy who was
at the cash register was like oh my God
you're [__] under hideyaki I love
everything you do and he wanted to brag
about it on Twitter that he met Arno
hideaki so what he does is instead of
just doing a standard tweet of just
saying like I met Anna hideaki he was at
my gas station it was awesome he took a
picture of his receipt no and put it up
being like see even his signature is
right there but the problem was was that
all of his credit card information oh my
God his car registration even where the
gas station was was just all there and
people are like ah you should probably
delete that
Rose losing his job and more oh he lost
his job yeah yeah yeah that's that's a
minimum of all actually the gas the the
gas station company I think it's
anything else had to make a public
apology
being like uh we're sorry that our
employee uh had a massive [__] up oh my
God someone that is someone getting sued
and yeah rightly so yeah right that is
all of your private information that you
know and amidst all the backlash you got
right of people being like what the [__]
right he was just like the only defense
he made was like no I swear it was the
real oh no and people like that's not
what we're on we didn't yeah we know we
see his [__] signature and all of his
private information we're not
questioning whether it was really our
note like we know we know the last four
digits of his credit card because you
[__] posted it yeah I guess he's just
out there then he's just out there yeah
now people have like starting to figure
out like whereabouts he lives and [__]
and it's just like all because of this
dumbass
just dumb [__] like that and the police
probably not doing anything about it I
mean unless something horrible happens
when TSA when they when they recognize
us and I just handed them my passport
I'm like bruh
I'm like [__] you could just
memorize this on YouTube post about it
or something I don't know I know that
they would yeah yeah
oh my god oh I had that the other day
actually at like my local uh corn bini
yeah oh yeah um like I have a company
really close to my house I'm not gonna
say which one obviously but like I went
there it was like at 11 p.m family mom
yeah one of the three
um I went there like 11 p.m I was just
like you know I was in my pajamas
because I was getting ready for bed I
just wanted to go get something and I
went give the guy you know all my stuff
and I'm just looking down on my phone
you know waiting for them to finish and
I just hear oh my God and I look up and
the dude behind the counter is like
you're the anime man oh God and in my
head I'm like rip I have to move now
because he spoke English I think he was
uh like Indian or Saudi or something
yeah so and you know he seemed like a
really nice guy
he was a brown boy he was a brown boy uh
but uh you know he was chill about it
thankfully but in my head I'm just like
don't you dare follow me out afterwards
after this purchase because I'm
literally right there oh no have you
ever had that like yeah someone
recognizing you really close to your
house yes yes it's terrifying and
everything actually there there's one
time where it happened literally on my
street
huh your street is not near March the
tourist stuff that's that's that's the
thing right so I was walking same with
mine yeah so so I was walking to my
apartment uh and uh I was on my street
and um uh I got recognized and my house
is really close and just to make sure I
walked like three blocks extra down and
then turned around and walked back
because I was I was like I ain't taking
this risk right now man this is
something new I'm experiencing now I
feel very vulnerable yeah uh but yeah it
is it is weird yeah but have you has
that ever happened to you as well oh
yeah yeah fair amount yeah but but you
know I'm just paranoid whenever I see
another white person near my house I'm
like
but there's a chance I like try to make
eye contact with them so I'm like come
on like if your sauce prove it hit me
give me the look give me the look give
me the look I'm like
my house because I'm like I just don't
want to risk it yeah
um yeah luckily there's a few entrances
so I can just walk around to them it's
definitely gone scarier now that you
know uh all the tourists are coming back
just I feel like every time I go out now
I'm more aware yeah of just every single
like non-japanese person who walks past
me I'm just like
yeah but I mean like if it seems like
every month now there's like a new video
popping up of someone doing something
stupid in a live stream or a YouTuber
doing something stupid yeah I'm like
come on man we're working so hard to try
to give like keep the peace here I mean
more content for me so yeah Joey's likes
bills thank you yeah yeah it's just like
I must be a good boy yeah and I'm like
oh this is this is what this is why like
[__] Charlie has so many things to
talk about like everything he wakes up
right I can see now yeah has it gotten
more difficult for you since like all
that news and stuff has broken out no I
mean again the the way I've always
approached it is that most places we're
like oh satsui this guy you know you
just ask them is it okay if I have the
camera you know and sometimes they'll
just flat out say no and it's like you
know if there's a bar that says no it's
not like you'll have difficulty finding
another bar yeah yeah and also you know
a lot of the streamers who uh do it
full-time like Rob uh Rob CD who streams
full-time you know he he goes to the
same places and interacts with them and
they're very understanding and they're
like yeah you're cool I know it's fine I
know yeah yeah customers and there is
there's some bars where they love it so
it's kind of just about finding those
spots and not shoving in a camera and
someone's face she doesn't want it yeah
um yeah be not being a dick IRL is is
super easy uh yeah tell that to these
other diggers but a lot of people make
it look [__] difficult yeah like you
just you just think you're going to
become like some kind of monster when
you're streaming outside yeah like it's
very easy to not be a dick I will I will
admit that every time I have seen like
news of just like some dumbass IRL
streamer in Japan you know making it
it's always somebody who's turning up
like it's never someone who lives here
but I always but I always but I always
worry for people like you and Rob that
you know yeah yeah this [__] keeps
persisting then it's just gonna put a
bad name on eye rolling oh for sure yeah
yeah it's definitely a worry because
it's like I think it's such a good
content uh it's great content type if
the person doing it it's done right
exactly exactly and it's so much
interesting stuff you can do in Japan
that's so cool you can do it and luckily
you know I I think I sort of he was
doing some kind of there was a guy
visiting he was doing who's blaring like
music in Disneyland and saying racist
things oh yeah yeah yeah
and stuff like that's bad because like I
mean you can't stream at Disneyland
anyway yeah you you know you shouldn't
be able to do that but
um you worried that other businesses
will be like flat out like no yeah but
luckily in Japan a lot of the cool stuff
anyway are not giant conglomerates it's
like it's just local stores that you can
just be like hey is it cool if I I won't
film any customers I'm just gonna do my
own thing and that's that's where a lot
of the best stuff is anyway yeah so I'm
not too worried about it but it's more
so the perception like people will be a
lot more kind of I feel Japan especially
and Japanese people are very easily uh
convinced and I guess like indoctrinated
by looking at negative media surrounding
you know things like streaming youtubing
stuff like that and think like oh well
if this one [__] did it then they
all must be like this right and you know
that's the problem with them just being
educated on the medium but it's like you
know you can't really blame them either
because only the bad [__] gets you know
gets published and then that just
reflects on all the other people like us
who are just trying to you know make
videos and stream and you know make it
an honest living yeah yeah and I'm just
worried that like it's people like that
that are gonna ruin it for the rest of
us well yeah it sucks that one guy going
around Disneyland chatting racist things
would get 10 times more media attention
than you know if I did like a cyclathon
race like yeah exactly in the Japanese
lens of things I mean that's just true I
think that's just I think that's just in
general you know I know I know well I
think a little bit online at least not
not not so much with traditional media
but at least online people are pretty
good at hyping up good events and and oh
for sure talking about them uh I mean
they very much love negative stuff too
um but you know you just gotta hope that
for every every one one brick you can
add someone doesn't tear down a hundred
uh I mean I mean it's difficult because
I think uh it's difficult to
promote something positive in the sea or
of negativity because I'm surprised you
said the online space because I think
the online space is the biggest space
that's kind of like accentuates negative
drives yeah negative like negativity uh
and I think that's just human nature I
think it's just human nature in general
you know we love spilling the team yeah
yeah I think I think it feels like
negativity is weighed a lot more and it
most certainly is but I find that like
the longevity of kind of positive uh
things you've done will maybe in the
moment not be as as big news as
something negative yeah I find that over
time people do remember us oh they they
do remember and also like I also think
that like
in terms of
um for streaming it kind of needs to to
have what YouTube has had where you know
in like Japan
um they have like hika kin right who's
like this they're like they're PewDiePie
Mysteries whatever you want to compare
like their biggest YouTuber having
someone like that be the face and who is
great for Brands and and people know is
a name brand want to work with it really
helps kind of uh establish creators and
I think that streaming just needs more
of that yeah it just needs more
established creators who work with these
Brands work within the rules do what
they say like legitimizes the medium
yeah yeah you know create great content
while not compromising but but also
keeping the people that are working with
um happy and and making sure that
everyone's kind of benefiting for sure
yeah um and I think streaming just needs
more of that um I think I think just in
general yeah I think right now we're
just streaming just just does a lot of
the big streamers I just I I whether
they realize it or not I think they're
just hurting the medium uh even though
maybe they're profiting and doing well
themselves I think the the overall
landscape of it is is like not great
yeah I mean I would argue that that's
just not in Japan that's just in general
in general too too but Japan needs it as
well because the thing the thing about
the thing I've noticed about streamer
culture
um in general uh you know even if there
are people making exciting content it's
just just because of this the way the
medium works the pure amount of hours
that's you know around content that
people produce uh a lot of that content
revolves around tea and opinions and
reactions you know and it's you know
we've you know with something like
YouTube it's much more controllable you
can make a certain video you have
someone like Mr Beast doing all these
amazing stuff and you know for every you
know [__] cyclathon chess boxing
event there is 10 million hours of
reacting to stupid tick tockers and uh
drama you know and and that's just that
that's just the truth of the matter you
know yeah yeah
uh and you just have to hope that the
platform will kind of grow up
[Laughter]
I feel like YouTube to its credit like
has matured a lot like oh 100 the the
the scene of YouTubers like think about
like genuinely like think about YouTube
drama it is so different yeah now from
what it once was yeah yeah four years
ago three years ago like it's completely
changed and I think streaming will get
that over time
um obviously I think it's a little
tougher because it's live people are
more emotional no editing yeah
um but but I think it will mature I
think I think it's it's like YouTube it
hit that mainstream drama was huge yeah
and then people realized hey maybe this
is not so good for business okay I mean
I mean just look at how often scarce up
was now yeah he barely uploads because
there's nothing to talk about whereas
before four or five years ago as you
said it was like every day there was
something happening on the YouTube yeah
and then a lot of the drama covered by
YouTube is often as streaming drama yeah
yeah exactly and I think I think that
maybe there'll always be a space for
that in streaming because it's more like
big brother yeah it's more Truman Show
yeah yeah he's gonna have that but I
think I think it will mature I think she
needs more time I mean I think one of
the big things actually uh interestingly
enough is that I think creators
themselves we just grew up yeah
officially like physically grew up you
know and we we are the audience that is
going to be the next generation of
YouTubers will will you know they'll
learn from us yeah they'll learn like
the way that we do things and and
hopefully they'll they'll they'll take
their behavior because because there are
genuine like YouTubers now who are let's
say Role Models you know who have been
on this platform for like a long time
and have like physically grown up and of
course there's gonna always gonna be
younger creators but unlike a platform
like Tick Tock which is like very very
young right now there's a lot of people
doing like a lot of stupid [__] on Tick
Tock
um that's just because it's it's a very
young platform and people have not grown
up with that platform so much as people
have grown up on YouTube also you know a
lot of streamers they're woman armies
maybe they have an editor or something
or maybe an assistant but you know
YouTube we're at the scale now where I
know I can count at least 10 plus
YouTubers I know with uh teams of 10 or
more yeah there are a lot of like these
are these are these are companies these
are all like businesses and you can't
you you don't want to be [__] around
with your livelihood of people who work
below you right yeah it's more about you
know I think again it's just a maturity
thing I think it's not not so much the
creators but it's it's the platform and
I think streaming will become more
mature over time which will help it I
think I think we'll you know now there's
uh you know you can go to certain places
and they have guidelines clearly laid
out for YouTubers or whatever to how to
film something you know and I think
it'll get there too yeah um and I think
side of Kit around it yeah I can only
hope I mean maybe it won't be and people
can play Devil's Advocate until I'm
wrong I'm stupid but I'd like to think
it'll mature yeah and I guess I guess I
guess we've unlike I I'm sensing like an
unintentional theme of this podcast so
far we're talking about the future a lot
so I want to bring up I want to bring up
gaming right let's talk about tech we've
talked about YouTube all right I saw
this I saw this video recently that's
the title yeah I I was just like I had
the light bulb moment what do we think
the future's gonna be okay so I saw this
video of this I think game in
development right now which is like on
like unreal five or something and it's
so photorealistic I it literally oh oh
is it the the one with the the first
person shooter one yeah yeah yeah the
one uh [__] what's it called were you
like killing uh people in like an
abandoned building yeah yeah yeah that
one have you have you seen that one oh